so how do you feel about flip-flops  versus the ones that constrict your foot  so there's a lot of people that will  tell you that flip-flops are bad they  are far superior to putting the foot in  a skew because the shoe is physically  going to deform it also the great thing  about flip-flops is they kick off really  easy and like being able to feel and  move the ground uh you know run around  in the backyard on the grass and have  some you know be able to move the foot  i'm not this hardcore like oh you've got  to live a barefoot lifestyle like you  know if i go out to dinner my wife may  dress up and put on a pair of heels like  yeah so but spend some time using them  and strengthening